a teacher once told me I was the  mistress of self reinvention like having  a secret  and nobody but me knows I'm doing it  I saw her I saw her from the train she  was she was with this man just for a  second so is this her to a woman so can  you tell me where you were Friday night  I was in the city and then I went to  visit my husband you mean your  ex-husband it's my understanding that  the woman who has gone missing who is  his nanny Rachel I need you to stay away  so what did you do during those hours  that night I don't remember yes some  time Missy  what happened that night Donna tell me  the truth you were seen in the area that  night  did you murder Megan hip well no  I'm not the girl I used to be  why are you here because I'm afraid of  myself  you